[Music]
thank you
in his essay on fairy stories and in
particular in the section entitled
fantasy J.R.R Tolkien is going to say
something very interesting not just
about fairy stories but about literature
itself and the other arts and their
capacity for being a vehicle of what he
is terming fantasy and the thing that
he's going to say is in human art
fantasy is a thing best left to words to
True literature that is to the Arts
that work primarily on us through the
medium of language and why is he going
to say this well we have to think about
what he actually means by fantasy and if
we're coming to this with sort of
preconceptions of fantasy as being a
genre of literature that we can find in
certain bookstores or categorize and
Tolkien fits into that we need to throw
that away we need to attend to what
Tolkien himself actually tells us he
means by fantasy so in that case we have
to distinguish it from what he calls
imagination right imagination is this
power that we have and he says that you
know it can vary in different strengths
and degrees but what's really important
here he says is another thing or aspect
needing another name and then he says
art the operative link between
imagination and the final result sub
creation sub creation is a major concept
outlined here in the work and he says
for my present purpose I require a word
which shall Embrace and then it is going
to tell us about two important aspects
and he says that this is derived from
the image right equality essential to
fairy's story I propose therefore to
aggregate to myself the power of how the
powers of Humpty Dumpty and to use
fantasy for this purpose Humpty Dumpty
famously says words mean what I say they
mean so Tolkien is telling us that
fantasy is something intimately
connected with fairy stories and what
are the aspects of fantasy so here the
sentence that I skipped over momentarily
he says I require a word what shall
Embrace both the sub creative are Alert
in itself this ability to create a
secondary world and secondary belief as
he calls it
so that's one aspect and a quality of
strangeness and wonder in the expression
derived from the image this is also
incredibly important there are a couple
other things that he's going to say
about fantasy that I think could be
helpful for understanding why he's going
to say that literature is its primary
home
so
um he tells us that
fantasy has an essential drawback it is
difficult to achieve so this should tell
us right off the bat that just writing a
story you know some fan fiction where
you've got like an ogre and the ogre's
got some problems because he lives in a
swamp a stinky swamp and uh you know
there's a princess and stuff that's not
necessarily yielding fantasy yet fantasy
is difficult to achieve now if you know
the story I was just referencing I think
that's a fairly successful secondary
world the whole Tolkien would be a
little bit iffy about it wouldn't he so
he says that fantasy may be as I think
not less but more sub creative at any
rate it is found in in practice that the
inner consistency of reality is more
difficult to produce the more unliker
the images and the rearrangements of the
primary material to the actual
arrangements of the primary world what
is he saying there well you know it's
easier to do realistic fiction than it
is to do fantasy isn't it and he goes on
and he says fantasy thus too often
remains underdeveloped and it's been
used frivolously or only half seriously
or merely for decoration it remains
merely
fanciful right so
it's difficult to do genuine fantasy the
other thing that is very important comes
at the very end of this section he tells
us that fantasy is a natural human
activity it certainly does not destroy
or even in salt reason and it does not
either blunt the appetite for nor
obscure the perception of scientific
Verity on the contrary
the Keener and the clear is the reason
the better fantasy it will will it make
and he he goes on and he says if people
were ever in a state in which they did
not want to know or could not perceive
truth facts or evidence
then fantasy would languish until they
were cured if they ever get into that
state fantasy will perish and become
morbid delusion and he goes on and he
says creative fantasy is founded on the
hard recognition that things are so in
the world as it appears Under the Sun on
a recognition effect not a slavery to it
let me say that line one more time
recognition of fact not a slavery to it
realism comes in different varieties and
the realism of genuine fantasy is a
genuine realism so to speak so fantasy
is not going to be at odds with
rationality and realism properly
understood
so he goes on and he tells us that
coming back to this point
um
fantasy is really going to be
working well in the medium of of
language and he's going to only talk
about two different other Arts one in
just a sentence and the other for
several pages so he talks about painting
and we could extend this perhaps to all
the visual arts the ones that don't
involve movement animation character
that sort of thing uh being developed
but but are static so you know sculpture
or murals or pick whatever else you want
that is being depicted in what we could
call the still image even if it's in
three dimensions and he says that within
painting the visible presentation of the
Fantastic image is technically too easy
the hand outruns the mind even to
overthrow it and he says that silliness
or morbidity are the frequent results so
that's an interesting way of of writing
off the static image as opposed to what
we can develop in our minds through the
language and we'll come back to that in
a moment
what about drama so he tells us that
drama is naturally hostile to Fantasy
and he also tells us that it's a
misfortune that drama an art
fundamentally distinct from literature
should so commonly be considered
together with it or as a branch of it
now
why
well
think about the difference between a
play and we usually say a play and we
mean the written uh account right the
dialogue the stage directions all of
that stuff but the play Maybe capital P
is really what is performed what is put
before our eyes
you know I took a world literature class
back when I was in college and in it we
read you know some novels for example we
read uh namakaz Lolita and we read short
stories including Jorge Louis Borges The
Garden of forking paths and we've read
poetry and we've read some of the most
ancient things provided we read you know
the Epic of Gilgamesh but we also read
that we also read uh Dante portions of
Dante's Inferno we read also some drama
for example
Ashley's Agamemnon which I thought was
really great
and when we read a play we're reading
how the play should develop and that's
more akin to literature what a real play
is though
what happens up on stage with the
people who are depicting and presenting
and embodying characters and the plot
and all of that Aristotle was smart
enough back in ancient times to say yeah
play isn't just the thought and the
dialogue and the plot it's also
spectacle and music and these other
aspects that are important as well and
drama is that when we go to see uh you
know for example we just saw Much Ado
About Nothing we didn't go there and sit
our butts in the seat and have somebody
hand us William Shakespeare's play and
then say let's all read through this we
watch the characters on the stage so
that's what a real drama is that's what
Tolkien has in mind
and Tolkien says that among these
misfortunes we may reckon the
depreciation of fantasy and this is you
know kind of a a problem here and he
tells us that fantasy even of the
simplest kind hardly ever succeeds in
drama when that is presented as it
should be visibly and audibly acted
fantastic forms are not to be
counterfeited men dressed up as talking
animals May achieve buffoonery or
mimicry but they do not achieve fantasy
and so he's going to talk here about
what he calls a a bastard form pantomime
you know the kind of things that are
presented for children and he says that
uh the nearer this is to dramatized
fairy's Story the worse it is it's only
tolerable when the plot and fantasy are
reduced to a mere vestigiary framework
for farce and no belief of any kind in
any part of the performance is required
or expected of anybody and he talks
about watching a children's pantomime uh
the the straight story of Puss in Boots
with either in the metamorphosis of the
ogre into a mouse and he says
um
though it was done with some Ingenuity
of lighting disbelief had not so much to
be suspended as hung drawn and quartered
so he's dismissing this sort of you know
aimed at children pantomime uh debased
sort of drama even if it's working off
of a fairy story it's it's not really
effectively doing that we might ask ask
ourselves actually do Disney adaptations
of fairy tales actually fall into this
they're generally not very good from a
plot perspective now what about drama
proper get away from the kids stuff
you know what about MacBeth he says in
Macbeth when it's red I find the witch
is tolerable they have a narrative
function and some hint of dark
significance though they're vulgarized
poor things of their kind they're almost
intolerable in the play they would be
quite intolerable if I were not
fortified by some memory of them as they
are in the story is red
and he goes on and he says a reason more
important than the inadequacy of stage
effects is this drama has of its very
nature already attempted a kind of bogus
or shall I say at least substitute magic
the visible and audible presentation of
imaginary men in a story that is itself
an attempt to counterfeit The Magicians
one so drama is already engaging in a
kind of Magic
it's not the kind that's really
congenial to what
Tolkien is calling fantasy he says to
introduce even with mechanical success
into this quasi-magical secondary World
a further fantasy or magic is to demand
as it were an inner or tertiary world it
is a world too much
to make such a thing may not be
impossible I have never seen it done
with success so he's not saying it's
totally out of you know out of bounds it
could never happen he's not making a
statement about you know the nature of
things as such he's just saying I've
never seen it actually pulled off so he
goes on and he says this is the the the
reason
um
the characters and even the scenes are
in drama not imagined but actually
beheld drama is even though it uses a
similar material words versus plot and
art fundamentally different from
narrative art thus if you prefer drama
to literature or form your critical
theories primarily from dramatic critics
or even from even from drama you are apt
to misunderstand pure story making and
to constrain it to the limitations of
stage plays you are for instance he's
just giving one example likely to prefer
characters even the bassist and dullest
to things very little about trees as
trees can be got into a play now we
should pause here for a moment and think
about you know what might be said about
film and TV shows and all these other
interesting adaptations that take place
in our vast streaming media scape that
we now inhabit where sometimes you know
shows may have hundreds of millions of
dollars even billions of dollars spent
upon them to try to put them in front of
us viewers and give us a fantasy that we
can indulge in
you might think about the lack of
success of some of these for example the
poor adaptation of A Song of Ice and
Fire to the show Game of Thrones or we
might multiply instances as well it's
being put before our eyes we're not
being asked to imagine except perhaps at
a very occasional places within the
story where someone says oh you can't
see this this is happening off scene as
a matter of fact you could say that TV
and film are even more than drama
putting things right in front of our our
faces right things that would ordinarily
be happening off stage can be brought
directly on stage so this is why Tolkien
thinks that's naturally hostile to
Fantasy but what about he says Theory
and drama
those plays which according to Abundant
records the elves have often presented
to men these can produce fantasy with a
realism and immediacy Beyond the compass
of any human mechanism
oh okay so fantasy might be possible
there
but he says as a result their usual
effect upon a person is to go beyond
secondary belief if you are present at a
fairy and drama you yourself are or
think that you are bodily within its
secondary World you've entered now into
the drama itself you are you know
perhaps a minor character but you are a
character and he says the experience may
be very similar to Dreaming and how's it
would seem sometimes by men Ben
confounded with it but inferion drama
you are in a dream that some other mind
is weaving and the knowledge of that
alarming fact May slip from your grasp
to experience directly a secondary world
the potion is too strong the and you are
given you you give it primary belief
however marvelous the events you are
deluded whether that is the intention of
the elves is another question they at
any rate are not themselves deluded this
for them is a form of Art and distinct
from Wizard rear magic properly
so-called they do not live in it though
they can perhaps afford to spend more
time in it than human artists can and so
well what is fairy and drama in this
respect he doesn't give any examples of
it and we might think less of drama per
se
and more of other immersive experiences
like that of playing
video games that suck Us in right and
where we take for a little while the
secondary world that is created as a
primary world and it can have fantasy
characters you know you can play a Lord
of the Rings video game or something
like that or any other Fantasy games but
it's not fantasy in Tolkien sense
you are perhaps using your imagination
to some degree but it's more having
imagination poured upon and imposed upon
you
and you're invited just to participate
in it so very interesting discussion
here about what the proper vehicle of
fantasy could be Tolkien is very clear
that he thinks that it's going to be in
the medium of language and particularly
in what he's calling true literature